[Música]
es la bienvenida a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta que hoy nos lleva a
cabo a uno de los estados que conforman
inter probablemente el más turístico del
país con más de 7 millones de visitantes
cada área roja también fue la única
colonia portuguesa en un subcontinente
dominado por los británicos el
territorio se unió a la india
independiente hasta 1961 14 años después
del resto del país el primer ministro
indio de la época no ha apoyado a
dictador portugués al azar así que india
decidió lanzar la ofensiva militar con
la operación beehive 32 mil soldados
indios lograron adueñarse de goa en tan
sólo 48 horas esta página de la historia
aún divide a la opinión algunos ve la
ofensiva militar como una anexión otros
hablan de liberación poco tiempo después
de este episodio coa se convierte en un
paraíso frente al océano índico
atrayendo a miles de turistas
hoy en día agua sigue tentando a miles
de soñadores en el mundo es el único
lugar en línea en donde todas las
culturas se mezclan como en ninguna otra
parte
[Música]
es una tierra exuberante frente al mar
de arabia sus playas de arena se
extienden kilómetros y atraen desde hace
tiempo a los viajeros del mundo entero
los indios también vienen para descansar
y a tomar el sol lejos de su vida
agitada y las grandes ciudades
contaminadas y superpobladas del
subcontinente pero en cuanto el sol se
acuesta sale a relucir otra faceta de
este paraíso costero coa también es
renombrada por sus fiestas electrónicas
hasta la mañana siguiente
[Música]
alistair letón tenía 19 años cuando
llegó a goal babor y participó en las
primeras fiestas fue hace 20 años hoy en
día esta es su casa y vive de su pasión
esta noche es ser quien está al mando
como un pez en el agua entre los
noctámbulos a la 1 de la mañana la
fiesta sólo está empezando para lista a
ir el mundo nocturno en goa es más que
servir alcohol y hacer bailar a los en
fiesta 2 es una comunidad una gran
familia
es el destino festivo de india ocurren
muchas cosas durante las fiestas no son
sencillas hay acuerdos que se negocian
incluso matrimonios que se celebran
durante las fiestas pero esta temporada
estuvo un poco complicada
ahora goa se volvió un poco la salida
del fin de semana porque los
occidentales no pueden venir con visas
de turismo en este momento entonces hay
pocos occidentales actualmente tan solo
los que quedaron bloqueados aquí y la
mayoría de los turistas indios no vienen
por las playas en general quieren
participar en las fiestas y disfrutar al
máximo no siempre fue así o así que
conservando la herencia de un pasado
memorable
fue la cultura hippie la que trajo mucha
diversidad aquí hay gente de todos los
países lo ve y dicha diversidad es lo
que hace de este lugar un lugar especial
i
en los años 60 las playas de arena
virgen de goa se volvieron el lugar en
el que se reunían hippies del mundo
entero con frecuencia caricaturizados
como yonkis nudistas sin metas y
desempleados la comunidad hippie
contribuyó sin embargo a moldear la
identidad y la economía de la región
muchos nunca se fueron de madre india me
lo dio todo sabe tengo 74 años pero aquí
aún tengo 20 tal como cuando vine por
primera vez agua mar y hamburgo es
francesa descubrió a hace más de 40 años
a lander sin goma
y aterricen goa y sentí instantáneamente
una libertad total en el único lugar en
india en el que usted tenía una
comunidad internacional mezclada con los
locales los one y sis entonces era
mágico mágico mágico
bunga villa aquí veníamos a hacer yoga
es un lugar extraordinario
esta noche maría nos invitó a reunirnos
con viejos amigos que se ven aquí todos
los martes
[Música]
schuchat
no
habéis son es aceptable y su vida
sustentable
el grupo se conoce desde hace decenios y
sigue viniendo para compartir una cena
unas copas y juegos traca el anfitrión
de la noche es una especie de leyenda
local es de california y llegó a la
india en 1969 cuando otros
estadounidenses de su edad combatían en
vietnam
es necesario
bueno ya no tengo el prerrequisito para
el hippie room porque ya no tengo pelo
pero bueno incluso sin pelo largo sigo
estando orgulloso de ser un hippie en
los años 60
aún estaba lejos de ser un destino
turístico no había electricidad agua
potable tuberías ni verdaderos baños
entonces era para los iniciados aquellos
que podían vivir en esas condiciones
uy nosotros creamos la música el arte el
movimiento ecológico etcétera una nueva
forma de resistencia política una nueva
forma de conciencia no le teníamos
confianza a la autoridad y era la
ventaja 5 a no había autoridades nadie
para decirnos lo que teníamos que hacer
y aún hay mucha libertad en goa hoy en
día aún puedes hacer un poco lo que
quieres pero bueno la nueva generación
no tiene ganas de desnudarse en la playa
los primeros extranjeros que llegaron
agua se enamoraron de la vida local y de
las playas vírgenes una belleza tropical
que trataron de preservar
cuando viajamos durante el verano no
pronunciamos nunca la palabra agua
siempre hacíamos alusión a la playa
pero el resto del mundo no se demoró en
interesarse en goa en los años 90 los
turistas son cada vez más numerosos
millones cada temporada actualmente el
40% de los ingresos del estado vienen
del turismo una bendición pero también
una maldición ahora muchas playas están
invadidas de bares hoteles y
restaurantes los casinos flotantes
cubren los ríos y difunden toda la noche
música a todo volumen
pero cuando los en fiesta 2 se acuestan
y los parlantes callan una nueva forma
de turismo responsable surgen
la bahía está bajo la presión del hombre
todo el día son las 7 de la mañana y el
sol aún no sale con fuerza cuya mitra
embarca a su grupo de turistas del día
para una salida eco responsable hacia
los estuarios y manglares
y quiero agradecerles por habernos
elegido y apoyar nuestra causa porque
tratamos de cambiar el turismo en go
tú ya está encantada con las costas de
goa desde su infancia como adulta se da
cuenta del impacto del turismo y del
desarrollo de la región en el medio
ambiente y decide actuar en 2017 crea su
empresa terra con shows para promover un
turismo eco responsable y cambiar las
mentalidades
lo que te sustracción figuró filetes
miren este litoral es magnífico y se
dedican a recortarlo
hay tantas serpientes aves o hace parte
de los grandes lugares de la
biodiversidad en india y en el mundo y
sin embargo lo dañamos con nuestra
cultura de la fiesta como sin nada más
contar si todo esto desaparece y es
reemplazado por hoteles residencias o lo
que sea entonces perderemos lo que hace
que sea tan verde el bella la razón por
la cual a la gente le gusta venir aquí
hoy el mar está un poco agitado para
poder ver bien a los delfines
bueno por lo menos pudieron percibir los
entonces ya saben que no les miento
están aquí
los consumidores deben cambiar su
enfoque y ya no venir a aguas solo para
encestar se o el turismo de playa que
solo beneficia a una minoría si queremos
que el ecosistema se beneficia así como
las comunidades locales los visitantes
deben cambiar sus exigencias deben
abrirse a nuevas cosas al final de la
excursión los clientes de puya se van
con nuevas perspectivas
las obras y el desarrollo afectan el
medio ambiente temo que todos estos
manglares y bosques destruidos nos
vuelvan más vulnerables frente a los
ciclones las inundaciones u otra
catástrofe natural creo que la gente no
se da cuenta que queriendo una mejor
vista hacia las colinas los cultivos de
arroz o el océano todo desaparecerá si
seguimos destruyendo durante los últimos
años los ghaneses también se han dado
cuenta de la importancia de preservar la
herencia ancestral portuguesa que hace
parte de la identidad de la región una
memoria a la que unió emilio reveló le
ha dedicado gran parte de su vida de
paul vender
es un escritorio un escritorio plegable
de portugal me senté en este pupitre
entre 1959 y 1961 durante la transición
del régimen portugués a la república
india hoy en día el septuagenario dirige
el hotel reveló está convencido que es
entre estos muros que el último
gobernador portugués firmó con india el
tratado de rendición histórico el señor
rebelo guardó numerosas fotos y objetos
de la época colonial como este
certificado escolar perteneciente a su
padre redactado en portugués
este diploma le fue entregado a jose
revel hijo de rock marí a revel
originaria de cultura de 15 años
tenía tan sólo 14 años cuando los
portugueses abandonaron go pero su
memoria está intacta
tomar menos
el béisbol era temprano debían ser las 7
de la mañana
escuchamos bombardeos y nos dimos cuenta
que la fuerza aérea india bombardeaba el
aeropuerto hacia las 12 del día
escuchamos una explosión y mucho ruido
después tuvimos que las fuerzas
portuguesas habían dinamitado un puente
para frenar el avance de las tropas
civiles
el tiempo dejó su rastro en su hotel
pero el señor reveló se apega a estos
recuerdos con vigor y pasión su temor
más grande es que esta página de la
historia caiga algún día en el olvido un
temor que comparten muchos otros juanes
es a pesar de todo esta herencia indo
portuguesa única sigue siendo conservada
en algunos lugares e incluso valorada
por la población local este esfuerzo es
el más visible en fontaíñas uno de los
barrios latinos más célebres de goa aquí
las casas coloridas y la atmósfera
parecen y nader hadas
[Música]
aquí el aire que se respira es distinto
es muy especial no sé hay algo mágico
aquí este lugar posee una atmósfera
única montañas me importa me gustaría
mucho vivir aquí orlando de norohna es
músico se impuso como misión revivir el
fado vengo a esa música portuguesa
nacida en el siglo 19 caracterizada por
sus melodías y sus textos melancólicos
de niño
orlando paseaba en las callejuelas al
ritmo del fado en ese entonces tocados
desde los balcones
puedo imaginarme los años portugueses
los cantos que cantan y tocan el fado
aquí escuche bien podemos oír aire este
violín tocados por un hombre en su
ventana en casa siempre hablamos
portugués desde la infancia mi padre
quería que aprendiéramos la lengua
además del conca neto la lengua anda
lengua
orlando aprendió guitarra portuguesa en
lisboa y recorre actualmente india y el
resto del mundo para tocar con su grupo
su música favorita una tradición y una
cultura que trata de proteger para ello
fundó en familia un centro de artes
indo portuguesas único en guam
de nuevo cuando padres
la gente no conocía el fado en india y
tuvimos que educar su oído y explicarles
esta forma artística a la que estamos
conectados todo lo que hacemos aquí lo
hacemos con amor mucha influencia
portuguesa con un toque de juanes es mi
vida le dediqué mi vida a ella
[Música]
yo quiero
la identidad one esa es cosmopolita
despierta y está en constante mutación
cambio con el tiempo pero permanece en
el aire ese poco de locura y cierta
alegría inimitable que hace de goa un
lugar único en el mundo
[Música]
y llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta los invito a visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
para ver este y otros contenidos en
español hasta